welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy with no
work-life balance and this video we're
breaking down severance on apple tv it's
by far one of the best shows this site
of the 20s and the ben stella led series
maintains its mind-bending motif all the
way until the end now the show itself
follows the employees of lumen a company
whose work is so secretive that its
staff have to go through a procedure
known as severance in order to work
there the entire company is built around
its founding here who's very much seen
as a deity amongst his employees many
worship him and prop him up but like a
lot of churches and religions the
secrets that they share have to be kept
from the outside world boiled down to
its simplest terms severance basically
involves splitting one's consciousness
so that a person perceives life inside
of work is being completely isolated
from the outside this is vice versa as
well and this is very much two versions
of a person created through the
operation the person who's undergone
severance cannot share memories with
themselves and thus they very much live
two lives now the one side of this sees
someone basically living like they're
never at work and they have no
relationship with their colleagues or
people from the company they even
stagger the entrances and exits of the
employees so that there's less chance of
them meeting on the outside world the
other side of this consciousness never
leaves work and then they end the day
and immediately start the new one they
just spend the days either at their desk
or christopher walking through the
corridors until they find a connection
now as someone who's worked a lot of
self-destroying 12-hour shifts back to
back in my past jobs are really related
to this and i remember being on shift
and feeling like i'd never left the
place you're just stuck in this constant
cycle of working and the characters in
the series are further left in the dark
by the fact they have no idea what
they're actually doing there they're sat
there day in and day out literally
crunching numbers which is of course a
metaphor for dead end jobs like this
sure once in a while they get five
minutes of dancing but it feels like
what boris tells us a downing street
party was like and it's not much of a
break as far as they're concerned
they're gonna be stuck there until the
day they die or manage to get
resignation which is also somewhat death
for this version of them now in order to
leave you have to basically get your
audi version to agree that you can quit
however to them they're just basically
kicking back putting their feet up not
experiencing work and still getting paid
for it there's no real reason why they
would ever want to leave this and we
watch as one of our protagonists helyar
feels like she's trapped in hell because
her opposite won't allow her to quit
there is of course a duality here in the
show name as in work terms severance is
often used when you're getting rid of
someone i also don't know if hellyer is
a hell pun but throughout the series she
constantly tries to escape this idea of
wanting to be free is laced throughout
her personality and even when we're
first introduced to her she's trying to
get out of the induction room as quickly
as possible now she's been brought in to
replace an ex-employee known as pd who
had lots of issues with lumen and
severance itself on the outside petey
goes to our second main character mark
played by adam scott mark is apparently
a widower and the majority of the
characters feel like they all took on
severance because they're trying to get
away from the pain of their memories on
the outside it adds a lot of complexity
to the characters as we watch them in
the outside world and actually feels
their points like it's more depressing
and being stuck at work all day however
we learn later on in the series that
mark's wife is miss casey the wellness
coach who too is trapped down there like
the rest of them peter gives mark a map
and after he mysteriously dies mark
makes it his mission to try and find
exactly what's going on with lumen to
make matters worse we learn his neighbor
mrs selvig is actually his boss and the
real driving force of the show is about
finding the mysterious conspiracy that
lies at the center of it it all came to
a head in episode 8 when salvik was
fired miss casey was sent down to be
reformatted and now four characters from
mdr launch a plan to awaken on the
outside dylan remained behind to set it
off and we closed out this entry with
them all suddenly being snapped into
consciousness on the outside world we'll
get into the consequences of this and if
you enjoy the video then hit the thumbs
up button and also subscribe for
breakdowns that are absolutely
unforgettable or something along those
lines crap crap on that anyway that
takes us in episode 9 where we watch the
characters all waking up mark is shocked
by the fact that he has a sister irvin
finds himself in his basement painting
the elevator that leads to the lower
floor and helio is at the gala ever
since the reveal in episode 8 of her
wearing flashy earrings many have
theorized that she's actually an eagan
and we get it confirmed in this first
conversation throughout the series we've
had several hinted at being someone
special and in episode 2 milchik said it
was amazing what she was doing there and
that it was like a miracle hey when we
heard you were coming here it was like a
miracle
it's amazing what you're doing
milchik is of course aware of the
outside world and therefore he would
know how important she was at one point
she looked over the first female ceo of
the company and talked about wishing how
she remembered her own childhood it's
beautiful
it almost makes me wish i remembered my
own childhood
she probably knew this person from her
own childhood and seeing this sparks
something off in her subconsciousness
there's also the fact that her audi
version said that she had to remain in
severance because of how important that
it was however she did it in a really
threatening way and promised to make her
like hell showing just how much she
needed her to stay inside i am a person
you are not she told herself that she
wasn't a real person and though this was
initially viewed as being extremely
cruel it also hinted at the fact that
helyar is just a task that helner is
carrying out we also saw the gala being
prepared in episode a and knew that the
board would be assembling there for the
speeches so the flash of hair all
dressed up kinda gave away the twist a
week early still though really impactful
and i almost feel like going back
through the series to see what other
clues there are that she was involved
here she meets the senator and his wife
who were somewhat of a mystery
throughout the entire show now it turns
out that she ended up participating in
severance because she wanted to endorse
the controversial technique it's very
much an undercover boss situation where
she went in to see things firsthand and
through this she could talk about how
good it was going through the procedure
herself would be its biggest endorsement
and mean that for everyone who talked
about how cruel it was for lumen to do
it you'd have someone at the top who
could shut this conversation down helena
is clearly very business driven and she
has a completely corporate mentality
because we know helly hasn't had a good
time she attempted to discover her
fingers and almost hanged herself in the
elevator helena completely ignores all
this because she wants severance to be
seen as successful so that she can
continue making profits for the company
everyone is enamored by kier and in many
ways i think that she'd view herself as
a failure if she didn't live up to his
legend so one of the things you learned
growing up as an eagan is that the
workers are our family she had the idea
trust in her hair that workers are their
family but this isn't really the case
and it's all a pr statement which this
entire exercise very much feels like
corporate propaganda is ripe in the
series and hell in his entire role is
trying to enforce this this propaganda
is also seen in the wellness sessions in
which people have fed lies about how
nice and kind that their audi is as she
goes through the gala we hear the buck
reading over the top which really adds
to her discovering you
not you her but but you
yet the cat eats the shrew and we
like schrodinger live on to wonder what
it means
now there's also mention of
schrodinger's cat i thought experiment
that hypothesized if a cat is put in a
box along with a toxic substance that
it's potentially in two states until
it's observed this substance could be
knocked over killing it which would mean
that the cat is dead however this may
not have happened and thus the cat may
still be alive it's very much in two
states until it's looked upon and the
cat is both alive and dead much like
those in severance who exist in two
states than either of which are whole
now about the gala we see photos of her
which were taken by milchik earlier in
the season these are all of her smiling
even though we know she was the complete
opposite of this and again it's
propaganda used to hammer home a point
from her father we learn that she's been
in a lot of pain over everything which
again ties into severance being a form
of escape he then thanks her for going
through it which explains why her enemy
was so resistant to everything she never
really wanted to do it herself so there
was a side of her that was constantly
trying to escape kia has a structure to
it where they want everyone separated so
that they're unable to come together
this is why the paintings of the two
departments attacking each other existed
and why each section is kept separate
unions are very much something that
corporations try to dissuade because it
tips the power balance which those at
the top would of course be worried about
severance stops workers from coming
together under one unionised banner
because it stops people from forming
meaningful relationships both inside and
outside of work helena was sent in as a
trojan horse to show it's the best way
to do things but this completely
backfires when her privilege and mission
is wiped from her memory and she sees
things from a workers perspective her
arc culminates with their taking to the
stage to deliver a talk about how well
severance works so that it can be rolled
out across the entire world however
instead of helner hally is there to tell
the truth about it she delivers
bombshell after bombshell and is
escorted off
listen
we're not happy we're miserable
we're
prisoners alive
however it looks like the damage is done
and though helena regains control
there's a lot of things that could end
up happening in season two which we'll
talk about later on after the titles we
cut to dylan to see that the gift he
requested was a photo of the team
together dylan learning that he had his
son was a massive part of his arc that
pretty much pushed him into deciding
that he needed to shut down severance
and i love how this is very much
reflected in mark upon coming across his
sister he assumes that the babies of
stairs wanders around the book reading
party and clearly has no idea what's
going on after speaking to ricken we get
some more of the backstory filled in
such as him suggesting that mark gets
the procedure clearly everyone is being
lied to you about gemma and it's a
cover-up on an industrial level that
completely masks her death now it's
during this time that he accidentally
calls mrs salving mrs cobell and this
sets off alarm bells for her that the
overtime contingency is now in effect
it's dylan they've been plotting this
all along ellie's at the gala i'll take
care of helly i'll fix her like i'll fix
everything now knowing that hely is at
the gal are about to deliver a speech
she heads there desperate to stop her
before she takes to the podium cobell or
salvig or whatever you want to call her
was completely loyal to the company and
i actually think that come the second
season that she will be rehired by them
her removal from the organization
allowed for overtime to be enacted
whereas if she'd been there she likely
would have stopped the entire thing
knowing what we know about helio it also
makes sense that she was fired instantly
for covering up her attempted hanging
lumen clearly don't mind losing
employees and it's likely that selvig
has presided over several deaths before
however helio may have been the thing
that got her cut because she was so
important to the company but going
forward i think that milchik might end
up being the one who's let go whilst
she's brought back in under his watch
over time happened and he's instructed
to stop dylan i think milchik might even
end up becoming an ally on the outside
as he's someone who's aware of what's
happened in and out of lumen and he did
build a camaraderie with the whole crew
look at those dance moves now he of
course awakened dylan and was the reason
why he came into contact with his kid so
some fault definitely lies at his feet i
just can't see the guy being kept around
no matter how much paintball or coffee
cozies he tries to bribe people with
tries to get him to do a flip on what
side he's on hey that's a that's a
little spiderman joke for you there now
erwin comes across his dog named radar a
palindrome which is spelt the same way
forwards as it is backwards this is very
much mirroring how his two sides are
bleeding together and it's a little
subtle detail that i might be reaching
over now elena's father was also in the
navy a fact that he proudly displays
about his home with several of his
medals and belongings out there however
these might actually belong to irving
and shout out to ryanairy for pointing
out that he might have severed himself
because he suffered from ptsd this would
make him perfect for the procedure as
he's trying to get away from it he's
also somewhat of an insomniac which
explains why he was always tired at work
even though he suspected he loved a bit
of a party also can't believe i shouted
out ryanairy shut the [ __ ] up ryanairy
now his audi and innie are very much
starting to bleed together which is why
the black paint shows up at his job and
why he also loves art he ends up coming
across a list of lumen employees that
he's compiled which outlines their names
and addresses on a map almost like a
radar hey now something is clearly going
on with a character that we aren't yet
privy to he of course has all the
paintings and the names even though as
far as we know he hasn't been down to
the testing floor yet however i believe
that he probably has and just in the
same way that ms casey or rather gemma
was sent down there to be wiped that he
may have been there in the past too
perhaps in his quote-unquote past life
he managed to gain consciousness and
then he slowly started to collect all
the names of the employees that worked
at lumen this was discovered and they
sent him to be reset but something
remained behind the list stayed at his
house and then he ended up having
flashes of the elevator of his own which
he then painted now this is almost
completely black which juxtaposes the
brightly lit corridors of lumen lumen
means to live together which they all do
but it also comes from the word luminous
which means light the corridors
themselves are filled with bright lights
inside the company whereas the outside
is darker than the dc universe this
corridor completely changes that and
feels like the darkest part of the
entire place now he couldn't really
understand why he painted this and
clearly his audi has been really
affected by what goes on in the company
this could also explain what happened
with gemma and she may have been reset
several times and kept down there so
that she isn't discovered on the outside
by mark now mark has been told that she
died in a car accident so potentially
his audi memories were filled with two
on the testing floor and it makes sense
that i have employees that are loyal to
the company and need to remove things on
the outside to stop them leaving now the
car accident did indeed happen and
helena hints towards this by telling him
in episode 1 to keep his eyes on the icy
road
sorry
maybe keep your eyes on the icy road
this is how gemma apparently died but i
think that lumen likely took her body
and experimented on her this could speak
to their overall goal to bring all the
eagan family back by placing chips into
people's minds which gemma might be the
prototype for potentially we could get a
get out situation where they're
attempting to put their own minds into
the body of the dead so that they can
come back to life and basically keep
keep on trucking their own bodies would
be completely rotted away at this point
so they'd need fresh ones to implant the
chips into now in irving's home he finds
a newspaper article talking about a
severed worker who sues for information
following an inquiry at lumen if we
pause the footage we can see in the
caption of the paper that the man
pictured is the council for a man named
mr emery in the article we learn his
name is dalton emery and potentially
this was irving's past life now we
learned that irvine's surname is bailiff
and this has several meanings to it in
the uk it means someone who seizes and
takes things away whereas in the us it's
an official and a court of law that
looks after prisoners irving very much
feels like he's the one keeping all the
employees in mdr online because he's the
most senior member he's tried to make
contact with several of the severed and
i think his ark in season 2 might be
about going to the other employees to
find out what they can tell him there's
also the theory that he was one of the
first people to receive severance and
potentially it was initially used in
soldiers the military tends to be where
a lot of things are tested before
they're rolled out and who knows he
might have been killed before being
brought into lumen this would also
massively mirror gemma and yeah there is
something going on with the dead that
we're not fully sure of yet now i don't
know if you've seen bloodshot yet but
minor spoilers for that you should have
watched in lockdown but that contains a
soldier who has his mind constantly
reset to hide him from the horrors of
the jobs that he's committing this might
explain severance's military application
and i i think it lines up but let me
know below if you disagree now amongst
the addresses he discovers bert's name
and he drives her to his home sadly he
finds up birders with another man and
irving has a breakdown whilst banging on
his door back with mark he finally
speaks to his sister and they decide to
go to a journalist in new york to reveal
the truth he also brings out the fact
that cobell has been masquerading as a
kind neighbor to the family hide your
wife hide your kid and though she
doesn't take them she speeds back to
lumen whilst milchik tries to get to
dylan selvig makes it a helli and fails
to stop her and thus she finally
delivers her speech mark finds a photo
of him and gemma and he rushes to his
sister devon and scream she's alive
which is when we cut to black now going
forward mark will likely be put back
into severance with his memories of
gemma on the outside world i think that
pd's map will come in handy even more in
the future and that they'll slowly start
to explore all the lower floors they
will potentially discover her down there
and irving could also end up learning
the truth about his past as well as why
he sees the elevator i think this will
be when lumen's true goal to bring care
back will be revealed it could also
explain the goats and typically you
carry out animal experimentation before
moving over to humans still have no idea
what they are and it's very much a
situation like the polar bears in lost
and there's also the rogue group in the
outside world that are helping with
severance we know very little about
these and i love the theory that they
might actually be working for helena who
wants to destroy the program potentially
she kept herself in because she knew
that she'd expose it and she might
actually want to escape her overbearing
father and bring the whole thing
crashing down my dad used to make me
recite the nine core principles before
bed every night which i can't say i
always did happily sorry dad my dad
would love for me to sit here and say
that i'm taking this job out of loyalty
i think there's a lot going on with the
company that we haven't scratched the
surface of yet and as i go into my
review i'd love it if you typed out your
best theories below now as for my
thoughts on the season i have to say i
think this is easily the best show of
2022 so far much in the same way that
devs took a high level concept and ran
with it in a really creative way ben
stiller has managed to build something
head scratching that feels like a must
watch i actually had two attempts at the
show and the first time i watched it i
accidentally put on episode 3 first i
sat there with a wife like well i heard
it was confusing but i didn't think it
would be this bad and kinda gave up on
it i'm so glad i went back to it and
watched it in the right order as there's
a lot of commentary here on office live
working nine to five and what can happen
if you don't get the balance right on
wednesday apple announced that the
season two request had been granted and
i can't wait to see what happens next
time because this is just so intriguing
it definitely feels like the show has
been asleep a hit and it's kept asking
some big questions each and every week
there's also some performances and
subplots which really add to it all and
the creative team managed to do a lot
with very very little when you think
about it the sets are pretty simplistic
the acting is extremely understated and
yet there's a power to the whole thing
due to how well it explores its concept
for that reason i loved it and seven
season 1 gets a 9.5 out of 10. now i'd
of course love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we are in a competition right now
giving away three copies of spider-man
nowaday home on the 15th of april and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the season if we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on twitter heavyspoilers you want some
emails to watch then make sure you check
out upright and a moonlight episode 2
which will be linked on screen right now
it's just as head-scratching as a show
so definitely go check it out right
after this as we try and explain it as
easily as we can if not thanks for
sitting through the video you're getting
severance without the pay
and i'll see you on the next one i
probably won't after that crap crap joke
but have a good weekend yeah peace